كم يحتاج نجم هوليوود من الجراه والشجاعه
كي ينتقد اسرائيل لانه يقوم عمليا بانتحار
مهني لن يظهر على شاشه ولن يعرض عليه
سيناريو في المستقبل لذا من اليوم الاول
تراكض 700 من مشاهير هوليوود لتوقيع عريضه
يبدون فيها دعمهم لاسرائيل في حربها على
غزه
بالمقابل اطلقت احتفاليه فلسطين للادب
بالفست مبادره لقراءه
اجزاء من التهم الموجهه لاسرائيل في محكمه
العدل الدوليه وشارك في المبادره 29 فنانا
وكاتبا من مختلف دول العالم بينهم اربعه
من كبار نجوم مسلسل صراع العروش المسلسل
المعروف انت اذا وقفت الى جانب محكمه
العدل الدوليه لن تكون معاديا لاسرائيل او
للساميه انما تكون داعما للعداله الدوليه
وهذا موقف حضار
gen in the brer of israel's conduct
towards palestinians during its 75 year
long
apti 56 year long biger occupation of
palestinian territory south africa is
highly cognizant of the fact that acts
of geno are distin from other violations
of international law san or perpetrated
by the israel government and milit in
gaza
اذا هم يقراون ما كتبته جنوب افريقيا لا
احد منهم يتحدث من تلقاء نفسه احتفاليه
فلسطين الادب هي مبادره من شخصيات ثقافيه
عالميه لخلق افكار ولغه خطاب لمقاومه
الاستعمار في القرن الواش انتم كيف علقتم
على مساله عندما سالتكم هل يمكن ان يلقى
هؤلاء الفنانون في هوليوود مصيرا مزعجا
كونهم انتقدوا اسرائيل رابح بكريش يقول
قال الفنان والتر تشارلز دانس انه يتضامن
مع فلسطين ويؤيد محاكمه الاحتلال بينما
الفنانون العرب صم بكم عميم وكان
شيئا ما يجري في غزه من مجازر وتدمير
وتهجير لا يعنيهم في شيء الفنان العربي في
خبر كان محمد احمد هناك تغيير كبير في
الوعي العالمي مع قضيه فلسطين ازداد
المتعاطفون معها بشكل كبير وازيل عنها كذب
الصهاينه ميساء الخطيب قالت بالتاكيد لن
تمر مساندتهم للحق هكذا سوف يتهمونهم
بمعدات الساميه تلك التهمه المعلبه التي
سائمه الجميع من تكرارها نهيك عن مطالبتهم
بحذف المسلسل من المواقع ومقاطعته عادل
عبده بشر في اعتقادهم يعلمون ما قد يترتب
على هذا الموقف لكنهم شجعان عبروا عن
موقفهم وقالوا كلمه حق في زمن يفيض ظلما
ونذر فيه الصادح بالحق التحيه لهم ولكل
الاحرار في العالم اخر تغريده من شاهر
يونس يقول سيحاربون يهمش كما فعلوا سابقا
بغيرهم مثل ميل جيبسون بعد الام المسيح
وغيره فالماكس مائيه اله ويوديه تعمل بوقو
هم لا ينسون ونحن ايضا لا ننسى خسرت
الممثله اذا كنتم تذكرونها وهي حائزه على
جائزه الاوسكار سوزان
ساراندون خسرت في نوفمبر الماضي دعم وكاله
المواهب التي مثلتها بسبب تصريحات لها
خلال تظاهره مؤيده لفلسطين رغم انها
اعتذرت بعدها على انستغرام ممثله اخرى هي
ميليسا باريرا بطله الجزئين الخامس
والسادس من سلسله افلام سكريم قررت دار
الانتاج استبدالها في الجزء السابع بحجه
انها معاديه لساميه بعدما تحدثت عن تطهير
عرقي في غزه